i remember meeting the producer at the
studio on my first job and he said took
me into his office and he said brett
every day you can pick one scene to make
look really good
beyond that just make your
day do you think if you were still
moving to los angeles today that it
would take you
five to ten years to
find steady work as a cinematographer
it's hard to say but i'm gonna
go out on a limb and say probably not
the reasons being are that there are
tools today that didn't exist in 1990
you have the internet you have
film industry
groups and
associations you have
um
uh
you know access like when i started
shooting the only way to shoot quality
work was film cameras which were very
expensive and very hard to come by and
the film was expensive and the
processing and tren and the telecini
and if you shot on video it looked cheap
and crappy but even those cameras were
expensive there were no inexpensive home
camcorders um
and so it's you know i
i could shoot something on my iphone and
you could cut it into an avengers movie
and you would never know
that that is just an incredible paradigm
shift
you know you can cut
films on your phone you can cut them on
your computer you know those things did
not exist um you know now you've got um
youtube and influencers and
web shows uh and um
you know so many more things now how
long it would take me to crack in you
know to the more professional stuff like
you know feature films uh it's hard to
say but it would be a lot easier to make
quality content it would be a lot easier
to access other filmmakers
you know i mean back in the 90s you know
how how do you find anybody you know i
mean now you just pop on facebook and
you jump in a group and boom there you
go you're surrounded by them you know
and if that if that group is full of a
bunch of shitty
people with bad attitudes you just go to
the next group
you go to multiple groups um
yeah it's a very different
world so i think i think maybe not i
think i think i would have i think it
would have happened faster uh you know
whether the big stuff would have
happened faster or not i don't know but
i would have been up and running making
films faster almost for sure
and just as a side note you said you
were crashing on a friend's couch or
floor i was on a floor on a little foam
egg crate
you know the little
mattress toppers and not only that but i
slept i continued to sleep on that for
about a year even when i got my own
place i had a i had a one bedroom in um
at uh vermont and the 101 in koreatown
and and and it was literally a one
bedroom and there was three of us and at
times more because you know we were kind
of the underground railroad for houston
when people would come out i'd be like
come on out and i and i paid forward my
friend's offer where she said um you
know you can come out and stay for free
for a month and that was kind of my
policy is you can come out you stay for
free for a month give you time to you
know find a job and a place and and you
know get you know get in a place where
where you're comfortable and secure
and i think you know we helped some
people you know get their starts that
way i'm very proud of that
what's the strangest uh part-time job
you had on unrelated to film
during that time
during that time
i
probably
there was some
job that i only vaguely remember but
this guy would pay me
to go and audiotape like school plays or
musicals on a little cassette recorder
in retrospect i'm just like what was
that all about i don't even really
remember it but but it happened so yeah
that was the strangest thing really
interesting where'd you find that job
i don't even remember much about the job
i have no idea
what did roger corman teach you about
the business of filmmaking
well roger corman personally and
directly taught me nothing because i
didn't work i never worked with roger
i met roger and he's a really nice guy
and he's like a big kid he was so
excited about this
cheesy monster that somebody had
repurposed you know very affordably
i think he was more excited that you
know they had
repurposed it for next to nothing than
you know what they had actually produced
with it
but you know
he had a very
i'm sure he still does have a very uh um
sparkly and wonderful personality and
this deep mellifluous voice that you
could just you know keep talking roger
that sounds great
um
but in terms of the precedent that he
set at the studio he ran new concord new
horizons um
it definitely taught me a lot of things
because you know it was it was you know
it was called colloquially concord
school of film or roger corman's school
of film
and um and it really was a lot of people
got their starts there you know you go
they weren't always concord because you
had new world and some other other
things but he gave his he gave starts to
people like you know ron howard got his
first directing opportunity um you know
dennis hopper worked for him uh gail and
her jim cameron i mean these are they're
all way before me of course but you know
they're in in that in that in that realm
of of of roger corman and
you know there wasn't a lot of of money
he he has this book that's titled how i
made
you know 200 movies i forget the number
200 movies never lost a time
um you know he would do things like uh
you know get martin sheen
and you know he'd be on the cover of of
the the video box and then you realize
what actually happened is that roger
paid him for one day and they shot
little scenes that they cut in through
the movie you know that's smart you know
people buy a movie because martin
sheen's on the cover well there you go
um so you know i learned things like
that um i um
i remember
that
and this wasn't me this was my friend
who worked in marketing he they would
send him out with a clipboard into malls
and they would just have these titles of
non-existent films and he would ask
people you know which which movie would
you go see
which is interesting because that's how
sharknado originated they had the title
they didn't even have
the
the script and i know the fellow who
wrote that and he said they when they
decided to make it they conceived it as
a straightforward
you know serious movie and he said you
said no that's this is this is something
we've got to have fun with
and and somehow he got them to trust him
and it became what it became
but you know again things like that you
know things like you know what really
sells a movie you know is it the fact
that i take great pictures or this
person does great acting i mean you know
i think that's what brings a movie home
you know but what gets the butt in the
seat is the title or the fact that
martin sheen's in it
from a practical point of view i
remember meeting the producer at the
studio on my first job and he said took
me into his office and he said brett
every day you can pick one scene to make
look really good
beyond that just make your day
and you know being a very
proud artist you know i'm like okay i've
got to game the system how do i make
them all look really good
and and so i was coloring outside the
lines i mean what's the
you know what can i do you know that
that's you know outside of the normal
parameters and one of the things i came
up with was that i would show up to set
every day
an hour or two early
and i would do diagrams i would go and i
would be in the set without blocking or
anything but i have a sense you know of
what it was i i probably had gone with
the director and talked talked through
it i don't remember that but i probably
did
um but anyway i went in there and i
would place some lights i would
on my diagram i would be like you know
this is the lighting scheme in here and
that's the lighting scheme in there and
i would go through all the sets because
they were you know those sets on a sound
stage
and then when the crew would get there
um you know i would walk them through
the sets and the first set we would we
would get it lit and then after that if
i didn't have time i would just hand
them the diagram and say here go set
this up so i was micromanaging them and
i would have them light two and three
sets ahead now the limitation with that
is you have to have the equipment but
this was a studio the equipment was
laying around
and this is something that i've always
incorporated you know any time that i
that i am able to you know i sell that
to people is i will
move faster if you give me the equipment
to pre-light so i'm not going into a
room and starting at square one that
you're walking in and it's roughed in we
just have to tweak and shoot
so you know that was one of the
advantages and part of that reason was
because
literally to my astonishment i would i
when we were shooting i would walk into
the bathroom and i would no
sooner have stopped and gotten ready to
do my business then the door would open
or ba would be saying we want you on set
you know i mean i just had no time so i
had how do you how do you hedge that bet
and that was you know one of the things
i did um another thing that i did
because we often didn't have the thing
we needed um you have to think out of
the box how can i do this differently if
i don't have dolly track if i don't have
that light if i don't have the cucularas
if i don't have the thing i need to do
the thing how do i make it work
so it got me thinking really creatively
and sometimes you completely reconceive
a shot you know and and sometimes that
challenge makes that shot even better
you know and um
so so that's just you know that's a just
a really a revelation but also it got me
into the habit of where
you know if i needed something to break
up light and i didn't have it um you
know or whatever i needed i would just
go walk around the studio which was an
old lumber yard and i would look in
trash cans and in corners and i would
find these little treasures i'm like i
can use this
and it's funny because years later i was
working on torque for warner brothers
which is a 55 million dollar action
movie i was shooting second unit
and
i had uh martin henderson was the lead
actor and i had a scene with him
and the light was too clean on his face
i wanted to break it up
and i had these you know really
experienced veteran grips
and i had this huge 10-ton grip truck
outside
and they're like what about this what
about this what about this and i'm like
no no no no no those things are right
and and so i i walked around and just
walked around and i found this old
raggedy plastic
c47 bag you know clothespin bag and i
was looking i was like you know what
this is and i and i walked up and we had
a leco on his face and i put it in there
it was just perfect you know very subtle
but it it took the edge off the light
and i'm like this is it and these guys
are looking at me like i'm crazy and you
know they bring a c-stand and they clamp
it and they thought it was so funny they
found a spare pelican case and they you
know they called it the
x-z-47 or whatever and that was now that
was on the truck
but but you know it's it's you know it's
it's easy to take the thing off the
shelf and to use it
you know i mean anybody can do that
but um i i really
am very happy that i got pushed into
that position
of learning to macgyver learning to
appropriate
you know what was handy i was on a shoot
just the other day
and uh
we were shooting an interview with
somebody and in the background there was
this white pole
and you know everybody's freaking out we
don't want to see it can you go with a
different angle and you know there was
angles which showed sliding glass doors
or the light was bad on the actor's face
and i just took some two-inch get black
gaff tape and literally just put it on
the face of the pole towards the camera
another one of my favorite stories is i
did this video with um rob thomas called
lonely no more
and
there was a scene with him in close up
and he's got these shiny glasses on and
i wanted a reflection in the glasses
and we did not have a because they're
convex you know they show a pretty you
know wide degree of range i didn't have
anything white
wide enough that you didn't see the end
of it
and in a moment i said you know what get
me
some a roll of paper towels and a c
stand and i took that roll of paper
towels i put it on the c stand i just
went
i raised the c stand up and if you see
that video if you go to my website and
you'll see this the thumbnail for it has
this white line it's toilet it's a paper
towels
so
i could give you so many more examples
of that but those are the kind of things
you know when you don't have the stuff
when you don't have the thing when
you're shooting low budget you know when
you're challenged when you don't have
the time you know don't don't don't
think of it as a handicap embrace it as
a challenge because
really it will make you a better
filmmaker and and sometimes maybe more
often than not what you come up with
will be even better than if you had the
thing to pull off the shelf
and when you do have free time do you go
to swap meets or thrift stores and look
for things where you because it sounds
like you just have this keen eye for
like
intuitively you know what's gonna work i
i don't i mean for me it's it's an in
the moment kind of thing i mean if i if
i saw something like um
you know every once in a while i've
bought you know little lights and little
tchotchkes but i don't um
i don't i don't go looking for it i do
try to balance my time you know and not
be in work mode
all the time although i am a little bit
of a workaholic when it comes to you
know both networking and also mentoring
i probably push myself a little more
than i ought to i've gotta you know find
that balance again with personal time
but
but um
yeah it's uh
i've had a few dreams in my in my life
where you know i would i would wait you
know i would be dreaming that i was on a
set and i
and a light was broken or missing and i
would just get so worried about you know
how do we fix it and how do we and then
i wake up and i'm like
i have to have this conversation with
myself that it was a dream because i'm
so upset
and so involved you know or those dreams
where you dream that you're on set and
then you wake up and it's time to go to
set you know it's
you know so i try and i try and i try
and not be on the clock
24 7.